Luke Bryan under fire after he dips wife
Caroline to baby kangaroos for Christmas
they bring a lot of emotions Caroline's
Bret's barn goose the 41 year old
country superstar surprised his wife
with marsupials over the holidays taking
to Instagram to reveal the newest
additions to the Bryan family and that
the Roos named Margot and Todd are
adjusting perfectly but PETA is not
happy about it the vice-president of the
animal rights organization Coleen
O'Brien released a statement on Friday
urging the musician to quote right this
wrong PETA is also calling for an
investigation into where the little ones
came from writing in part they belong in
their mother's pouches not in gift bags
these Joey's have complex needs
including specialized diets and room to
roam they are not toys but according to
the national animal advocacy nonprofit
born free USA in Tennessee where Luke
his family and the diaper-wearing Joey's
currently reside they do not regulate
private possession of certain wildlife
including kangaroos the American Idol
judge has yet to respond but noted the
ruse will be raised as part of Bret's
barn the farm he and his wife launched
this year in honor of her late baby
niece the barn which houses all sorts of
rescue animals is also a foundation that
raises awareness for congenital heart
disease and Down syndrome and Luke works
with local charities to bring kids out
to see the animals at the barn
[Music]